clôture de plus de 2 m fils de fer
barbelés caméras de sécurité n'entre pas
qui veut chez sur le g forbes
le champ compte dix mille plants de
cannabis et l'espace suffisant pour en
planter quarante mille autres ici on
croit que l'avenir de l'industrie se
déroule à l'extérieur plutôt que dans
des serres même s'il n'est pas possible
de produire l'hiver
moi je pense qu'on a de meilleur et
c'est parce qu'on utilise l'énergie du
soleil qui gratuit pika aucune effet sur
une planète qui devient des enjeux
politiques importants
quand la culture extérieure à grande
échelle et ce fut possible au printemps
2010 9 marc leblanc ya vu une occasion
d'affaires il a investi 8 millions de
dollars et il essaie m'économiser
plusieurs millions en cultivant ses
plans dehors
ça serait dépassé un million par mois au
niveau de coûts d'énergie justice et ce
constat l'intérieur
substantielle énorme c'est qu'il ya
quand même un coup climatique à cinq
millions le pam aux sauces et un
nouveaux cultivars qu'on a utilisé cette
année le coup climatique de l'industrie
du cannabis intéresse le chercheur david
joly à l'extérieur évidemment ballon
sauveur sur la lumière c'est sûr on
profite de la lumière du soleil donc il
ya toutes ces aspects-là qui rentrent en
ligne de compte donc on voit une
popularité comment ça vous mentez dans
le but de rendre le marché de plus en
plus compétitive dans que des gens qui
veulent se tourner un peu vers la
culture extérieure
depuis le 31 décembre 2019 le nombre de
titulaires de licences autorisés à faire
de la culture extérieure a presque
quintuplé au pays passant de 28 à 138
selon santé canada
c'est quelque chose qui on n'a pas
beaucoup des données fiables on a
beaucoup de confiance grisons qu'on
appelle une question qui interpelle
aussi eric anaruz avoir les défis de la
culture extérieure sont grands c'est
pourquoi les scientifiques comme elle et
david joly accompagne les producteurs
pour maximiser les rendements et limiter
l'impact de la météo à l'intérieur même
s'il peut avoir des problèmes de
maladies qui affectent les plantes donc
c'est évidemment plus facile de
contrôler l'entrée de ces maladies non
en milieu extérieur ben alors le vin
peut transporter toutes sortes de
champignons bactéries donc c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'avoir des
problèmes de maladie donc comme ceux
culture qui est encore nouvelle que très
peu de maladies qui sont devenues
importantes mais ce qu'on pense qu'avec
une augmentation en popularité
l'augmentation de la quantité de
superficie flamex on dédie cette culture
là on va voir des maladies qui vont
prendre de l'ampleur
l'objectif pour rivaliser avec la
culture intérieure atteindre un taux de
thc d'au moins 20% le sucre chercher par
les consommateurs mais avec notre équipe
les cultivars qu'on a l'histoire et
qu'on avait avec les plans qui
connaissent bien le nouveau brunswick
c'est pour ça qu'on attend que ces
objectifs là un taux que sur leur grande
forme ce affirme avoir atteint ce n'est
cependant que dans deux mois quand le
produit sera disponible sur les
tablettes des magasins que les acheteurs
pourront juger de sa qualité et sinon
tambour radio-canada rhinos
[Musique]